KATE BACHELDER ODELL:
I'm Kate Batchelder Odell
I graduated from Hillsdale
in the class of 2013.
And I'm an editorial writer
for The Wall Street Journal.
I spent a summer studying Latin
in England in high school.
And I was writing my dad these
emails about what was going on
and what I was up to.
And he wrote back,
you could be a writer.
And what you should do to be a
writer is to read and to write.
So it was just this
natural progression.
It was never this aha
moment, if that makes sense.
And Hillsdale was
just a good fit
for kind of lining up that
natural interest and curiosity
with some concrete opportunities
to write for the paper
but also do a lot of
writing in coursework.
I was the opinions
editor of The Collegian,
which was a lot of fun.
It was a very good education
in how to work at a newspaper.
Meeting my husband
at Hillsdale's
been one of my favorite
things about my experience,
because it's so
much a foundation
of the life we share.
Hillsdale is also an
education and learning
how to live with
others, because it
is being shipwrecked
in rural Michigan
with 1,400 other people.
Really lean into those
relationships and friendships
that are every bit as formative
and educational as some
of the more formal coursework.
I think people think
opinion writing is
telling people what you
think about various subjects.
The style of opinion writing
that we do at The Journal
is to report the news and put
it in a analytical narrative.
It's an institution.
It's more than 125 years
old, the editorial page is.
In a sense, you are a
steward of something
that will continue on long after
you're done working for it.
And so it's taking
care of something.
It was really an
exciting, wonderful honor
to get this award, especially
since so much of my life
I feel I owe to Hillsdale.
Almost silly to be receiving
an award from somebody who
gave you everything you have.
I'm honored but also just
amazed and kind of covered
in gratitude with it all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]